[Musique]
ce soir avec Antoine fenaud bonsoir
Antoine bonsoir allez direction la Côte
d'Ivoire ce soir ou l'armée française
est accusée par certains de soutenir un
coup d’état expliquez-nous absolument et
tout part de plusieurs publications
principalement sur facebook cette fois
notamment celle-ci que j'en ai regroupé
quelques-unes pour vous qu'est-ce qu'on
y voit on y voit des photos de ce qui
ressemble à du matériel militaire
français vous apercevez ici un blindé
c'est également le cas ici et plus
largement ici des soldats en tout cas ce
qui ressemble à des soldats français lui
il l'internaute qu'est-ce qu'il nous dit
il nous dit l'armée française se déploie
sur toute l'étendue du territoire
ivoirien Asan Pedro notamment retenez
bien son nom ça va nous intéresser
l'armée française a déployé à plusieurs
endroits de la ville avec des véhicules
et des chars de combat blindés selon lui
c'est ce qu'on trouve en dessous sur les
images qui nous proposent donc sur son
poste Facebook a également circulé ce
poste qui est accompagné d'une vidéo sur
Facebook alors la qualité n'est pas
extraordinaire mais vous allez
comprendre que ce que nous disent
internautes que l'armée française là est
en Côte d'Ivoire à Soubré et sans Pedro
là encore qu'y a-t-il exactement sous un
ton un petit peu suspicieux et de nous
partager également cette vidéo que je
vais vous proposer qu'est-ce qu'on y
voit c'est une vidéo tournée depuis une
voiture et on y voit des blindés
visiblement en français des véhicules
blindés qui sont effectivement de
fabrication française il faut le
signaler de dernière génération et bien
défiler sur la route de ce qu'il
présente est en tout cas comme la San
Pedro en Côte d'Ivoire on a également
trouvé d'autres publications notamment
celle-ci qui elle est bien montre une
vidéo d'un port hélicoptère le porte
hélicoptère tenait vous le voyez juste
ici et lui c'est internaute lui et bien
il dit et bien c'est un coup d'état tout
simplement c'est un coup d'État de
l'armée française qui veut déposer le
président en titre Alassane Ouattara et
un autre internaute il n'y va pas avec
le dos de la cuillère si on peut dire il
l'affirme complètement là encore San
Pedro toujours cette ville ce port de
Côte d'Ivoire et la présence de l'armée
française si selon lui ne peut signifier
que trois choses pour attaquer le peuple
malien qui veut s'affranchir on retrouve
là encore la rhétorique anti française
qu'on retrouve beaucoup autour des fake
news au Mali et soit à la salle Ouattara
vous le voyez réellement malade
gravement et ces jours sont comptés ça
on va y revenir un petit peu plus tard
voilà donc pour ces publications à Shrek
alors certains détails permettent de
retrouver l'origine du contenu de ces
publications oui absolument et je vous
avais parlé souvenez-vous il y a
quelques instants d'un porte hélicoptère
et ça c'est bien ça va nous intéresser
je vais vous reprendre la petite vidéo
un autre extrait de la vidéo de
l'internaute que je vous avais proposé
où il montrait ce porte hélicoptère et
un détail à attirer notre attention ici
à un fond à toi que si vous voyez c'est
ce numéro qui est présent sur la coque
du bâtiment l
9014 et bien nous on est allé vérifier
sur le site de la marine français s'y
est bien un porte hélicoptère portant ce
numéro d'identification existait et
bingo on la retrouvait le et on le voit
ici vous le voyez c'est le site de la
Marine nationale on retrouve ici vous le
voyez sur la photo que je vais agran
un peu plus tôt la légende elle est très
instructrice qu'est ce que nous on
apprend ici et bien et bien que ce
bâtiment avec d'autres forces françaises
notamment des blindées et bien
participaient à une opération un
exercice avec l'armée l'armée
ivoirienne et ça c'est déroulé le 10
novembre et également le 11 novembre
dernier à Rennes d'autres publications
Antoine affirment au cycle président
Ouattara est gravement malade est-ce que
vous avez des détails oui absolument je
voulais je vous avais montré ce poste
très alarmy c'est très alarmiste d'un
internaute et bien à la sanatara
rassurez-vous il va très bien parce que
le lendemain de cette publication il a
lui-même publié sur son compte facebook
une vidé une quelques extraits quelques
photos d'une rencontre avec deux
ambassadeurs suit de l'Inde ici et suis
du Burkina Faso c'était effectivement en
Côte d'Ivoire on le voit il est en
pleine forme donc vous le voyez ici il
s'agit bien évidemment d'une infox c'est
un mot également sur les photos que je
vous ai montré un peu obscur de ces
soldats français en patrouille qui ne
qui étaient un peu décontextualisé bien
ses photos on les a également retrouver
et là non absolument rien à voir
souvenez-vous cette photo que je vous ai
montré donc un petit peu plus tôt on la
retrouver donc sur le site de nos
confrères de l'afpn n'a pas du tout été
prise en Côte d'Ivoire mais en
Centrafrique à Boda plus précisément
vous le voyez ici et elle a été prise en
2014 donc rien à voir le moment où est
bien l'armée française souvenez-vous
intervenait dans le pays a noté
également que l'autre photo qui
accompagnait ce poste très alarmiste et
bien on a trouvé cette l'occurrence de
cette photo avec ce soldat français sur
un forum et bien dédié à la les forces
armées du Maroc oui c'était assez
surprenant là ce qu'on sait c'est que ce
poste lui date de
2014 donc un mot également donc sur ces
exercices que je vous donc que je vous
évoquais on a également retrouvé leurs
traces sur le site du ministère des
armées que vous apercevez ici ça existe
des biens donc de deux semaines
d'exercice entre les forces armées
ivoiriennes les FFCI et donc les forces
armées françaises l'armée française qui
était déployée plus largement dans le
cas d'une opération dans le golf des
Guinée en conclusion vous l'avez compris
pas du tout de coups des voix que de
coup d'État en Côte d'Ivoire fomentée ou
soutenu par l'armée française mais une
simple exercice militaire et
rassurez-vous à la salle Ouattara lui il
va très bien merci beaucoup Antoine pour
tous ces éclaircissements restés avec
nous sur France 24 Paris directement